[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
happy friday everyone it's gonna be a
great show tonight uh but first a
disclaimer
warning greg had an endoscopy earlier
today and is still coming down from a
strong anesthetic we're not responsible
for anything he says during the
following show
it's true not lying
so it's an especially happy friday for
me because yes i just had an endoscopy
that's when they shove a tiny camera
down your throat
to see how stuff's working everything
seems okay the best part is that video's
ratings were still higher than cnn's
but thankfully uh they didn't find
anything scary except for dana perino's
class ring
there's a few diamonds missing from it
but i'm hoping my proctologist will find
those next week
but in order to do that procedure they
put me on a drug that knocked me out so
forgive me if i make less sense than joe
biden speaking without a teleprompter
but at least i know what it's like to be
cat
anyway
last night a debate erupted over the
brooklyn nets guard kyrie irving who's
refused the covet vaccine now i don't
follow professional badminton
but this is now a big deal
since new york city requires proof of
the vacs for entry into the arena where
the nets play so on tuesday the net said
irving won't play until he's faxed but
he ain't doing it i mean what would you
do
what would you do
you know if you felt uncomfortable going
into the season uh when you were
promised that you would have exemptions
or that you didn't have to be forced to
get the vaccine i'm staying grounded in
what i believe in
it's just as simple as that it's not
about being anti-vex
or about being uh you know on one side
or the other like it's just really about
being true to what feels good for me i
chose to be unvaccinated and that was my
choice and i would ask y'all just to
respect that choice
now what's interesting about this story
isn't irving's reasoned opinion but how
it affects people who hear it it's now a
pickup game of the shirts versus the
skins see what i did there
check out the debate on this intriguing
program
it features five panelists
one really really hot guy
and it's on at 5 p.m but i can't
remember the name
rules are rules this guy is wrecking his
life right now for no real reason and
it's absolute stubbornness based on that
you know jesse nothing's geraldo you're
mad at this guy yeah
you're mad at me because he's full
he's not just hurting himself no but
whatever he's hurting everybody's like
you're being played you are being you're
can i finish my point you are being
manipulated to disagree with somebody
this is an artificial division and we
shouldn't play into this
mandate did
you know it's weird watching yourself on
tv while you're on tv
[Laughter]
don lemon does that to double his
viewership
anyway i fear that geraldo missed my
point that the anger he felt toward
irving was not caused by irving at all
it's caused by the situation created by
people in power in order to create
conflict to keep us at each other's
throats like joy and whoopi fighting
over the last eclair in the green room
the elites they like sweets the elites
are trying to fight a proxy war with
each other through the citizens and
unfortunately it seems to be working
irving was trying to focus on getting a
shot in the net not getting a shot in
the arm but geraldo felt genuine anger
toward him the same kind i feel towards
killmead when he won't return my swim
trunks
doesn't even own a pool
but the anger is misplaced it's fury
manufactured by the establishment who
are scared to death of liability and
therefore risk but they're also
terrified of you and me or me and
geraldo if we happen to ever agree which
is hard to do when you're looking at
that mustache
that thing's a whole different kind of
two-pointer
little sports joke
but if we all got along despite our
political health or height differences
it makes it that much harder for the
aristocracy to control you and for the
media to make a buck the people in power
lose power when we resist the traps that
they set for us we've seen how division
is egged on through media narratives
that aren't true
and politicians who need a target cnn
fostered the anti-police narrative and
wove it into a racial conflict that has
since mushroomed into a stelter-sized
monstrosity of lies and identity
politics
others who wish to pit the sexes against
each other do so because it makes
careers in academia and jobs for people
in human resources they do this with
gays and straights trans and gays dogs
and cats
fox and friends
conflict sells
that's why every good bond film has a
bond villain
and it's why cnn the view msnbc suck
while we push each other around in the
streets they're raking it in with their
click bait
if only we got along their jobs would
vanish faster than a story on hunter's
laptop and the people's power would grow
but now we're being pulled into new
conflicts vax versus unvax mask versus
no mask once you see how it's being
ginned up though you see it everywhere
take the nba player seriously why get
mad over someone you don't even know who
is making a decision for himself i mean
unless it's something like talking
loudly on a cell phone in a movie
theater in that case stab the jerk
don't stab the jerk that's a joke
but other than that just realize it's
cnn and biden administration trolling
you and us
right now it's kind of clear that
someone who's young lean and incredibly
fit such as kyrie
and myself
does not have the same risk profile as
someone with a pre-existing condition
unless unbeknownst to me kyrie once
dated cat he poses no threat to geraldo
or me or our families
i don't know what that means
but we are living in a time of
conformity and when you don't conform
you're shunned like gerald noddler
skinny dipping at a public pool
so whenever you feel yourself getting
angry at someone else and you're only
given two choices
it's a binary prison of ideas remember
that it's a desired phenomenon created
by a third party it creates content for
tv producers and it distracts the
populous from the real bad that's going
on like crime mental illness and my
relentless ibs caused by swallowing
class rings
if we fight amongst ourselves we can't
fight them and they can continue
ignoring real injustice and get rich off
you along the way
so mandates became just another tool to
split us apart but the media's argument
that there has to be a deep-seated
hatred amongst americans is much like al
capone's vault
once you crack it open there's nothing
really there
and once you see it you can't unsee it
much like when you see geraldo's
shirtless
sadly there's no vaccine for that
let's
welcome tonight's guests
he's a successful comedian
ed actor
which means at one point in his career
he was also a successful waiter
jamie lissau
her last name's italian for talks too
fast
outnumbered co-host emily compagno
his novels are so delicious they should
be in the cookbook section
up in the air author walter kern
she's got brains she's got beauty and if
you feed her beans she gets a little
tooty
boxton's contributor that's it
walter
the problem with this this coveted stuff
is that we cannot discount the fat by
the way it's nice to see you thank you
yeah i've missed you good to be here
yeah that's not cute shut up
[Laughter]
cannot discount the fact that people
when given the chance to feel righteous
you know from flight attendants to tv
anchors will take that shot right and
that's what i feel like what we're
seeing what do you think
when i was a kid we used to read a short
story in high school called the lottery
and it was about a small protestant
hometown in uh
i think vermont where every year to make
the crops grow the farmers formed a
circle picked one person and stoned them
to death oh really and so there's an
ancient instinct in people to uh make a
scapegoat pay for all the difficulties
of life you know in the thought that
maybe you know it'll bring back normalcy
if we
sacrifice them and and today it's him
but you know i remember when muhammad
ali wouldn't go to the vietnam war right
professional athletes are people too we
treat them like uh paid circus
performers then they come out show they
have a conscience and that they don't
need
the applause and acclaim that we give
them and uh
personally he's made all the right
decisions about his body his whole life
yeah he made it into the nba right i
think he's probably still making them
and that he's suddenly a [ __ ] is
ridiculous yeah that's true uh um the
lottery so you're saying that was a bad
idea
well not if you want the crops to
grow exactly
some things take priority jamie long
time since i've seen you
you've been living in uh where do you
live now still in fairbanks alaska
fairbanks alaska that's right try to get
geographically as far away from where i
would be successful
[Laughter]
well you've done quite well for yourself
you're successful in your failure
yes what do you make of this whole story
where do you stand or sit can i say
first of all i know you had the
endoscopy this morning and you're on
some drugs i want to apologize right off
the bat i'm also on some painkillers
because this morning i had access to
some
[Laughter]
so
that might be the best
joke i've ever heard
but then again i'm really high so what
does
it matter i've told that joke before no
one could hear cause i was in alaska
i feel like i think kyrie's brave yes i
think he's he's a he's a brave guy and i
think it's impressive because he's a
rich guy i think we can say he makes um
four hundred thousand dollars a game i
think i saw is that true yes greg for
four thousand dollars i would take the
anthrax vaccine yeah
i really would
and uh
and you could say and then i was
thinking like he could have gone the way
like i know lebron i think stephen curry
got the johnson johnson yes so he could
have just gone with that which they just
released today that they're saying the
johnson johnson vaccine is just as
effective as just having one of those
little circular band-aids
so
good to see you jamie it's good to see
you so much talent
it's such a such an empty state
i don't know what i'm saying emily
don't you feel this debate could be
easily settled if we just got rid of
lawyers and the media from the room
go ahead hey yes
in the media and a lawyer well i was
going to say but now i feel like i
shouldn't now you don't deserve it but
that i don't have that disclaimer in the
beginning passes legal muster
just saying um look here's here's what
kills me about that so kyrie actually
said it best himself in the beginning he
said what would you do if you were told
there would be exemptions exceptions
alternatives look at andrew wiggins from
the warriors who applied for a religious
exemption and he was denied we were told
that covid negative tests would suffice
for these athletes that chose not to get
them the vaccine in fact we were told
that within new york city we were told
that within the federal government but
that encroachment just keeps creeping
and so kyrie can stand to lose yes 15.5
million dollars which he will this
season that means he can stand to lose
it if he is but what about all of those
navy sailors that are being dishonored
or discharged less than honorably and
they're losing their veterans benefits
they're losing their pension these are
hard-working americans that have served
our country that are losing everything
that have mouths to feed because they
have chosen to have autonomy over their
body and made their own personal
decision religious or otherwise but if
it doesn't pass that that arbitrary test
according to some coach or some medical
examiner at that moment then it hasn't
been approved so the the mandate he's
absolutely right and the mandate is what
is difficult to stomach and everyone
stepping up against them with whatever
whatever platform they have we should
applaud rather than condemn yeah i don't
there you go
by the way i don't even think it's the
team it's
it's the it's the edict from the uh from
the government in new york that's
forcing the team's hand which is what
we're seeing we're seeing the government
freelance their authoritarianism
so that it's the company all the
companies now are going oh it's the
company's choice to do that and you work
at the company no it's the government
telling the company to do it by saying
you can't work here yeah and we've all
just gone completely crazy because you
watch that video and he says
it's my choice i'm asking you to respect
my choice he doesn't say boycott the nba
yeah he doesn't even say agree with me
he just you know you watch that you hear
someone say it's my choice respect my
choice and you think oh yeah okay yeah
and you turn on the tv and people are
like no
you know they're just like we're gonna
talk about what a horrible person you
are all night long actually and there's
a certain point where it's just complete
completely psychotic reaction yes just
someone be like that's my choice can
respect my choice yeah yeah it is the uh
it is but it's because we are forcing
people in the prison of two ideas
there's a million ideas million stances
between
and hey
there is i don't know why my hands are
still up here
i like you hi
i don't know what's going on
i took painkillers too right yeah no i'm
not kidding why why did you share i
threw my back out because i try to be
stealth when i'm stoned am i the only
sober one here that's insulting to me i
know it is insulting it's like if you
got him you got to share it i agree
unless there's like the crappy kind a
friend like tram at all yeah okay
craig on my painkillers on the back of
the bottle that said do not mix with
alcohol but i read that as this would
probably be pretty good if you mix it
yeah
[Applause]
up next diversity quotas get repealed
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else